this is the heading I'm going to ask you
to put a secondary heading on this
because up this is a very functional way
of describing what we're going to
looking at today but um traditionally
historically this is not at all what
it's become good boy ah these are called
and I'm not I don't you could try
pronouncing this one because I have it
unlike um I like the barbarous theorem I
haven't done the research to go that I'm
going to be saying this right so this is
a French mathematician who worked out
these results that I'm going to show you
um and that's what like this is a really
beautiful result that we're going to
look at okay it's all about the
relationship between the roots of a
polynomial and the coefficients that has
now you already know what some of these
are let's just rehearse for a quadratic
right we can stay any any quadratic
polynomial as like with general
coefficients in general form right so if
I have a x squared plus BX plus C equals
zero okay out of this I can make a
statement if I say the roots are Alfred
beat up because it's a quadratic so it
should have three roots I can make a
statement about what happens when I add
those roots and what happens when I
multiply those winds right now if you
recall how we got this relationship what
we said was look if I've got a quadratic
like this and you don't need to learn
less this I'm just gonna do a quick the
other side and we're going to do it for
the cubic it according if you have a go
at something like meters and you say
look this quadratic cannot have two
roots right or to have two roots I
should be able to say that I could
rewrite this not say it's equal to
something but actually say it's
identical to a quadratic that looks like
this oops love it okay it's got two
roots alpha and beta and I can't just
say X minus Alpha X minus beta and say
that's the factorization because I don't
know whether it's monocore not a could
be 1 or 2 or negative a hundred or
anything okay so that's what's at the
front ok now what I would do here just
like we did with in so many places right
because we're approaching the one object
from two points of view
I'd expand the right hand side and then
I have some x squared terms some X's and
a constant just like I have here and
since these things are identical
I will equate them I've compared
coefficients and then I get a result out
now this is for us what is that result
what is the sum of the roots of a
quadratic my spirit very good right
there's the summer fruits and in the
same way once you reverse that process
you get the product of the roots alpha
times beta which is just CNN right so a
couple of things have happened number 1
the coefficient has changed and also
it's gone from negative to positive
thank you ok so the end product of roots
now as it turns out southern products
are actually not a very appropriate name
as you will see as we now generalize
this result ok so now rather than just a
quadratic we're going to have a look at
a cubic at this time we are going to
fully rehearse this result rather than
just say hey do you remember this we're
actually going to go through the lines
okay so I'm going to say we start with a
general cubic right again I'm going to
name they the leading coefficient a so
ax cubed plus BX squared plus CX Plus D
okay now what I want to know is
something about the roots of this cubic
and how many roots should have it should
have three just like a quadratic has two
there should be three roots and I want
to know how they relate to each of these
coefficients okay so my method is going
to be just like over there I'm going to
say look this thing here it should be
equivalent to something which has three
roots
I want it completely factorized out
right so I have that out the front
because it's not necessarily money and
then if there are three roots I'm going
to call them alpha beta and gamma
okay in case you're wondering gamma I'll
draw a nice pink eye over here this is
the way I draw Gabor's okay um kind of
like a how would you describe
it's like a ribbon you know there's
rivets that you buy their fundraising
ribbons it's like a ribbon winner with a
tailor okay for a hat whoever it is okay
so here's my factorization now I'm gonna
take this I'm just going to expand a lot
okay now I'm going to give you a second
to excuse me
you're going to get a whole bunch of
turns out of this okay get all the terms
out just one by one if I take you a
couple of lines but the important thing
that what you get is can you gather the
X cubed terms can you gather the x
squared terms can you gather the etc now
just to make things one step easier for
you before you begin your expansion okay
before I expect you see everything here
on the right is going to have an A on it
right like every single thing is going
to have an edge because there's an a at
the front okay so rather than do that
I'm just going to take the a out of play
right I'm going to divide both sides by
a it's just the null but it's an odd
zero not because it's a cubic if a was 0
I have a quadratic
okay so find about everything I should
get X cubed plus this number of X
Squared's Plus this number of X's Plus
this constant okay so I'm divide that
all by a which just leaves me with this
which is very easier to expand but it
just worked me somebody as flying around
okay so now you've got the right-hand
side go ahead and expand it and collect
the life terms okay I figure I'm one
step short okay you can see what I've
done is I've actually just expand
everything out but I've put them into
groups I just haven't quite factorized
here right oh I pointed this out just so
that you know what are the tricky things
here is just making sure you've got
everything just make sure you have
missed any terms you're going to have
three x squared terms now just before I
you know actually factorize this how do
I know I had to have three x squared
terms like I knew I had to have three of
them okay have a look at how you get an
x squared out of this right in what way
could I get x squared and the answer is
you have to take these two which leaves
you with don't pick an X here because
then you won't get neck squared you'll
get an execute right you're going to
take these two are you going to take
these two and then you've got to take
those two
in other words out of three objects you
were trying to choose two of them right
in other words picking back to your
binomial that you live way at the side
of here
there were three choose two of those
right which if you want to go back to of
your path schools Fraggle right 3 choose
2 is going to be able basically choose
look 3 choose 1 3 choose 2 okay so
that's how I do then we're going to be
three and your calculator can check that
okay that'll be more useful we go for it
a bit so I also do there were going to
be three these okay you can see the 1 3
3 1 that Pascal's triangle expect us
together okay do you see it okay so all
right now ready to factorize so I'm
going to in order to make sure I can
compare the coefficients I need the
actual coefficients just sitting at the
front I notices it executes on both
sides but that tells me nothing about
the coefficients are written how they're
related to each other so I'm just going
to get rid of both of them do you see
that it doesn't add any useful
information to me I've got an X cubed on
both sides but whatever okay now see
where the action happens right how many
X Squared's do I have I'm going to take
out that minus sign because they all
have a minus on them and I get alpha
plus beta plus gamma right that's how
many X Squared's there are in the same
way I've got all of these guys take out
one factor of X that's you now these
guys what do you call them you cannot
really call them the sum of roots
because it's not alpha the speed of
scalar but you also can't call them the
product of roots because it's like
Alberta okay so so what you call these
is and if I write the last one here you
can see there's a pattern that I can
name these will be consistent is that
this is the sum of the roots but it's
the sub one at a time just one root then
the other one in the other one this one
is still a so it's something for
something you can something but they're
not one at a time they're two at a time
you see them they're all paired up okay
this is also a Sun but they just happens
to be only one object there right some
three at a time
okay so there's someone at times some to
the side some three Oh time those are
the coefficients that will actually get
and I can compare with it right so
therefore and here come the first of all
that rather ii prefer stop you
here come the second of your taste
results right he takes the coefficients
and compares them the first one is here
I'm going to put I've done the colors
you can see again but this makes it a
little more bees you've got Midas a
hospitable scrubber equals beyond a so
I'm going to put the by the side of the
other side as is traditionally done
right so there's the summer fruits and
that by the side pops on the other side
as you should expect based on this right
interesting
no matter how many roots there are no
matter what degree of polynomial is if
you add up all of the roots you'll
always get this result right
oh the next one is to two times so you
go alpha vena be together alpha and
gamma that's just here and he there's no
change of sign required okay so that's a
C or a and then lastly there's some
three at a time
yes - be on it all the time because on
Pascal's triangle you're not that far
off you don't that problem when we look
to fall you'll see what happens okay let
me write down this last one for the
cubic okay so this is going to be again
the side it switches right so you're
getting minus T on a and these are
beauties results to eviction equation
okay so again you can see just like we
observed here like it's actually the
same numbers it's the same numbers and
they also also data gets Sian okay